eventually anyways
um uh so there's a few of us here in Bic
124 and
um including two committee members and
uh the rest of you are online so um I
want to welcome everyone to
um a uh doctoral dissertation defense
we've actually had a whole bunch of
these in the last couple months so it's
great to see
um people uh finishing their long treks
so our speaker today is Wei Chun Lin who
uh probably most of you know has been a
PhD student in the department for
several years and um has now reached the
hopefully the end um and so
um I think most people know the usual uh
approach to doctoral dissertations the
um like thesis defenses where there's a
public presentation public questions
then the public is dismissed and the
committee remains and then the candidate
is dismissed and they decide if there's
a successful defense I don't want to
take too much of weight Sean's time but
let me just give a brief introduction
again he's been around the department
for many several years now as a National
Library of Medicine uh actually
postdoctor or fellow although pursuing a
PhD he
um originally completed his medical
training at changong University in
Taiwan where he obtained his doctor of
medicine MD degree with the double major
in traditional Chinese medicine he then
received a master of science in
biomedical engineering from Carnegie
Mellon and then he joined our department
in September 2017 and he's going to
present his dissertation today
okay thank you for the introduction so
let me share the screen
can you guys see my screen well
okay that's long time not have a
talk in this um classroom
so hello everyone thank you for coming
today I'm presenting my dissertation
work application of machine learning for
glaucoma surgical outcome using EHR data
so glaucoma is the second second leading
cause of irreversible blindness in the
world in U.S there are about two percent
of population was affected by the
glaucoma older than 40 years old
so what is glaucoma glaucoma is a group
of eye disease corrected by Progressive
feature field laws and optic nerve
damage which always related to The
increased intraocular pressure
but is it medication control is a
primary treatment plan for the glaucoma
to avoid program disease progression
however about 2 20 of patients
eventually need glaucoma surgery and
there are several glaucoma sexual
surgical methods including tropical
ectomy shell surgery
laser surgery and tropical lectomy is
one of the most common used glaucoma
surgery for the advanced patients
in tropical ectomy surgeon will remove a
portion of
trabucular mesh work and create a kernel
from the inside of eye and to the
outside of eye which drain out the
inside eye fluid and decrease the
intraocular pressure
however according to the study reported
tropical ectomy surgical value rate is
about like 28 to 32 percent so there are
some different definitions of surgical
value in General Circle value was
defined as a patients needed reoperation
or showing consistent High LP or low IOP
after three months of primary surgery so
those patients might need to take
glaucoma medication continuously
surgical value are mainly correlated to
the post operative complication
including the high IOP or low IOP or
other factors scarring is the most
common cause for the elevated IOP and
the blip leakage and other filtration is
common cause of the low IOP applications
uh some other communication may be
noticed like infection lip dysesia
malignant glaucoma in this study we will
focus on the communication related to
the high IOP or low IOP since the
occurrence of other vectors
because operative management is crucial
in the time sensitive the goal period of
the post-operative management is about
two to three months after the surgery
physicians may adjust their treatment
plan and the frequency of the filter for
the patient with higher risk of
complication for example physician May
decrease the steroid dosage or delay the
laser suture license time for the
patient with higher risk of coronary
hypotenate on the other hand
physician I mean it's just their
treatment for the patient with higher
chance of scarring they might use
post-operative anti-fibrotic agent like
5fu or use higher dose of topic steroid
so overall the success of tropical
lectomy surgery highly depends on the
post-operative care and the goal period
is around two to three months after the
surgery post-operative management is
complicated and maybe contrary due to
different cause of complication and the
complexity of surgical recoveries and
the different needs of operative care
makes a predicting long-term glaucoma
surgical outcome more challenging
therefore an assistant tool for
predicting which patient has a higher
risk of long-term surgical value with
different costs will be needed
so my first aim was to access the
possible EHR data that correlated to the
glaucoma surgical outcome and I did a
systematic literature review focused on
the AI application or for idc's using
EHR data
next my following M will address some
knowledge Gap and a limitation we found
in specific M1 so in the N2 I developed
several machine learning and a deep
learning model using both structure and
unstructured EHR data to predict
multi-class surgical outcome including
surgical success surgical value due to
high IOP and the surgical value due to
low iot
for the I know for the final M I try to
explain the develop model in the end to
and to identify the important features
or um explore the impact of this feature
on the prediction result
here is the overview of our study in the
M1 I did a literature review and data
assessment in the end to develop several
machine learning and deep learning model
and the model performance was evaluated
by several evaluation metrics in the
entry we did the model explanation to
explore the important feature and their
impact on the predictions
so for the M1 the systematically
literature review focus on the AI
application using your chart data for
the idcs and some risk factor of
glaucoma progression and surgery
um also I explored a different format of
EHR data including the structural EHR
data on structured data and medication
list
the review literature review work was
published in translational fission
Science and Technology Journal we found
several knowledge Gap and limitation in
previous study
based on our literature review few study
focus on surgical outcome prediction for
glaucoma application and there are
several notable knowledge Gap first most
studies use the single miniature such as
the IOP before the surgery or the early
post-operative biop try to predict the
long-term outcome however there are many
factors might correlated to the surgical
outcomes such as eye mingers feature
Acuity patients condition chronic
disease medication use or surgery itself
so use single mentions
sometimes it's questionable
and the previous study focus on the
binary surgical outcome that means
predictor surgery is success or fail but
the treatment plan for the
post-operative complication can be
different as like high OPP scarring
patient and hypotenuse patients they
need a totally contrary treatment plan
and the previous study did not include
intraoperative information some study
used the data before the surgery some
use the date of app that's surgery in a
small period but it's leaking the
information about during the surgery and
the sample size another issued
most studied the sample size is smaller
than 200 eyes
so they're still really a need to
develop a tool to assist with prediction
of surgical value due to iot changes
oh sorry it'll be better yeah sorry
about that
so the first step for the EHR data
assessment we identify the target
population for our study tropical ectomy
performed at KCI Institute from 2010 to
2021.
around 1500 eyes in 1300 glaucoma
patients were included in the inclusion
criteria was listed below as mentioned
before our surgical outcome focus on
surgical success value due to high LP
and value due to low IOP
sorry
so for the structured EHR data we select
50 features including four groups
patient's condition and eye mixtures eye
measures include multi-time points of
intraocular pressure and visual impurity
and medication including the oral
medication or eye drop for glaucoma or
the oral medication for the chronic
disease like hypertension or diabetes
and some other information related to
the operation itself and feature
selection with knowledge base and
data-driven linear imputation was used
to handle the missing numeric data in
addition some variables are incomplete
or missing in the structure format such
as conjunctiva report or modernizing
dosage used in during the procedure
modernizing C is a pretty important
anti-fiber optic agent that I used
during the surgery that help patients
decrease the risk of scarring after
surgery so we need to extract disk
information from the progress node or
search code node in the free text format
so we developed several regular
expression based tool to extract
information and close validate
information from the structure format
and unstructured format to improve the
data quality
for the unstructured EHR data we focus
on the surgical note surgical node
contents interoperative information and
might be useful for the long-term
outcome protection after data cleaning
we tokenize our road tax and develop a
custom word to factor model using the
sibo master and we create a 50
Dimensions work Vector in this what
factor will input to the prediction
model later
here is the example of surgical notes
physician May record a modernizing
dosage the time use and the patient's
condition during the surgery surgery
technique they use the blood loss and
some other information during the
procedure so
um here's the example for the cyclical
note
so here's an example of surgical node
pre-processing the road tax will cling
up and the question stopworth and
punctuation was removed and those tax
will tokenize and then each token will
link to an index in the custom
vocabulary and those index number will
convert to the tensor format which is a
array-like format that used for the Deep
learning model like pytor tensorflow
the last part we try to explore the
usability of medication lists so the
first question is this medication less
accurate to answer this question we
manually review 150 progress node and we
found some discrepancies between the
progress node and the medication list
um since the mainly review is time
consuming and labor intensive so we
decide uh develop a NLP tool to extract
the medication information
so we develop a natural language based
model for automatically extract active
medication and medication adherence in
the free tax progress node and
demonstrate a prototype medication
reconciliation tool using the
development model this work was
published at Amia and using Symposium
conference in 2021.
here's is the flowchart of the overall
overview of the study the first step we
manually annotate 500 progress known in
data was split into training and testing
and then we used a net entity
recognition to develop a model to
extract active medication the net entity
recognition is a type of natural
language process technique seeks to
locate classified name entities in the
text into predefined categories in our
study it's like a medication and
frequency or dosage
um and we use Spacey library in Python
environment and we create a
convolutional neural network to predict
each Nan entities
the model evaluation was using F1 score
Precision record and the micro aperture
score for all entities
and we also developed a prototype
medication reconciliation tool
here's the example of annotate nodes
including all entities such as drug name
the root of administration pre
prescription frequency the dosage of the
drug
medications Trends the duration and the
medication adherence and medication use
term
dragon and content is generic and brand
name and abbreviation current Medicaid
huge current medication used term was
labeled as a drug use and with the blue
color which is pretty important because
if we use this term to identify the
following medications active use is not
recording like past history medication
history
so there are some examples of this is
this label like eye drop iMat start
using taking or continuous
the table shows the result for the per
entity and average score for the all
entities the
um we can see the the model has a pretty
accurately to extract medication related
entities such as drug name frequency
root dosage and strengths but model
shows the lower performance on the
duration and adherence the difference
might be come from The Limited sample
size in the training data or the variety
of wording for some variables
so overall the model was very accurate
at identifying medication but less so
for adherence and the duration and the
model performance is similar to the best
performing published NLP model for
communication extraction
um with our developed model we can go
back to apply the model as a medication
reconciliation tool first uh the ner
model extract the patient's medication
and the drug use label the drug use
label was used to identify whether the
medication are currently used then the
drug name are standardized based on the
arc's known ingredient finally the
medication data was reconcile with the
medication list and the mismatch
medication of flag we apply this to
150 progress known in Gada F1 score
around 95 percent
so far our meditation study we found the
medication list may not be utterly
recorded So if we want to include the
medication information as a predictor
for the outcome prediction
um that's some issue for using each
unique medication as a predict because
that will generate a pretty loose data
set so we need to do some Dimension
reduction in our quarter patient in the
medication that's patient taking more
than thousands of unique medication
including the glaucoma medication or
Conan disease oral medication
so here is the example with design use
categorize the medication based on their
pharmacology mechanism so there are 10
unique Landing eye drops in the
medication list and if we categorize
them based on the mechanism then they'll
be narrowed down to one group so by this
way we can reduce the dimension
dimensionality and avoid some medication
list inocracy issue for a prediction
model
here the key takeaway of the M1 first
both validate EHR data with structure
and unstructured format could improve
the data quality and the surgical nodes
content interoperative information it
might be useful for the outcome
protection and medication that's
accuracy was questionable for glaucoma
patients and the developed NLP tool can
be used to help with medication
reconciliation and the categorized
medication based on their pharmacology
mechanism might be useful for outcome
prediction model
thank you
in the end to to address the challenging
and the knowledge gap for predicting
glaucoma surgical outcomes I developed
several machine learning and deep
learning model using both structure and
unstructured EHR data to predict the
glaucoma patient with higher risk of
surgical value after 30 days of primary
treatment
since the treatment plan for the
surgical value might be contrary or
different due to their costs so we try
to predict three classes as our outcome
Circle success Circle value due to low
IOP or surgical value due to high IOP
um surgical value is with like scarring
and continuous like High LPS easy to
understand but if after the surgery The
Continuous hypotenuse or the low IOP can
also can be a clinical emergency
condition in mind some procedure
intervention like needling or considered
reoperation so try to predict those two
different groups surgical value is
pretty important rather than just
predict surgical success or fail
um besides in our study we exclude the
real operation cases caused by the
infection and bleed disses sample size
is really small
let's quickly take a look at our study
design we did a data extraction and
preposition in the first step and we
develop several machine learning and
deep learning model and the model was
evaluated by several evaluation metrics
here is the list or of the model we
developed uh for the using structured
EHR data we developed five machine
learning model including our artificial
neural network random forests attributes
support Factory machine and logistical
regression with Alaska net penalty and
then random words shows the best
performance use only structure EHR data
in the street tax classification model
was developed using the surgical nodes
including the one dimension convolution
on your network model by the directional
long short-term memory model and the
Transformer encoder block classification
model the Transformer encoder block
classification model shows the best
performance and we also developed a
early fusion multimodal with Transformer
encoder block classification model try
to handle the structural data and
unstructured data at the same time
here is the early Fusion multimodal
architecture
um for the structure HR data The
Continuous
feature was normalized and the
categorical future was convert to the
one-hub factor
and the surgical nodes was handled by
the Transformer block with the setting
this here with 10 hats and 12 layers and
hidden units is 768 with dropout rate
0.1 the output of the Transformer block
will concatenate with the structured ear
chart data in a two more dense layer
with the battery normalization layer and
the Dropout layer were concatenated that
were connected
and finally we use the softmax function
to predict three class outcomes the
hyper parameter we use for the open
minds model was listed here
in general there are three common
strategies for the Deep learning model
Fusion early Fusion intermediate fusion
and lay fusion in our study we found the
early Fusion Shows the best performance
for our model
in the previous slide we showed the
architecture of modern neural network
where we use the Transformer block to
extract information from the text Data a
Transformer model is a neural network
with the mechanism of sales attention
and position embedding Which is popular
using many fields such as neutral
language reprocessing and computer
fission
for a classification problem we only
used
um encoder block to extract information
we don't need a decoder block which used
for the sequence to sequence model
so in in the um in Transformer encoder
blocks text Data was converted to the
pre-trend embedding metrics and then the
position Vector is add to the embedded
Matrix in order to enhance and maintain
partition of the word in the text
another important part is multi-head
attention which content a certain number
of different attention layer in order to
find out attention words from the
sequence and all this layer work in
parallel so in our study we use the 10
hats in the prediction model and the
output of each encoder is passed to the
next one and the overall output of the
encoder block can connect to the linear
layer like here or concatenate to other
input data in a multi-model design like
rs30 in a Transformer block Marty had
attention and the position of embedding
both provide information about the
relationship between the different
inwards and contextual meaning therefore
the Transformer block can Trend in
parallel and manage tax data in a
non-sequential way so compared to the
other recurrent neural network like long
short-term memory they treat the tax as
a sequential data each by each word by
words so using Transformer block can
avoid some problem of forgetting of
passive information in a long text in
our study even our
sample size of the surgical nodes is not
big the Transformer encoder block can
still work well to extract information
from the loan from those texts
our data set was randomly displayed into
80 as training and 20 at testing and a
five-fold cross meditation was used to
avoid overfeeding and to the hyper
parameter the model performance was
evaluated by AUC score F1 score
Precision recall and Marco averages
scores
here are some explanation of the
evaluation metrics accuracy determined
how correct values are predict and
recall is the ratio of correctly
predicted class to the all actual class
and precision is the ratio of correctly
predicted as to the total predict class
and the F1 score take care of the
information from both precision and
recall and gather average number
from from these two Miniatures and Roc
curve is a great showing the performance
of a classification model at all class
classifications ratio and the area under
the RLC curve choose the model ability
to distinguish different class
um here we only shows the
um best performance model from each data
format so blue shows the using both
structure and on structured vehicle data
and red is use the structure EHR data
only and the green color shows the um
use the surgical node only
so we found the multi-model neural
network with Transformer encoder block
shows the highest AUC score and F1
scroll so which indicator combined
interoperative information from surgical
node with important structure EHR data
may bring more information for the
surgical outcome prediction
this slide shows a detailed information
about the multi-model new neural network
result
the model has a good good ability to
identify the IOP cases or low IOP cases
surgical failure with a recall score
score higher than 50 percent which means
the model can correctly identify more
than 50 percent of surgical value case
so for example in our task data there
are 36 case with the high IOP surgical
value and our model can correctly
identify 20 of them
however the model shows the lower
performance for for the Precision
position for the low IOP uh prediction
so overall the multi-model with both
structure and unstructured EHR data
bring a distant result for multi-class
prediction
so here are three key takeaway from our
specific end to First multi multi-model
neural network with both structure and
unstructured EHR data can be used to
predict the multi-class surgical outcome
of the primary tropicalactomy comparing
to the previous study or even try to
predict the multi-class that's a little
bit more complicated than the binary
outcome our model still has a higher uh
ruc AUC score and F1 score and circle
nodes content interoperative information
is used for the surgical outcome
prediction and the surgical recoveries
of tropical ectomy are complicated and
hard to predict for the long-term
outcome so develop model could be an
assistant tool for the clinical decision
making
in the last M we do an extension study
from the specific N2 we try to explain
the develop model in the end to and to
identify important feature and their
effect on the prediction result
although the multi-modal neural network
shows the higher AUC score and it has
better performance currently there are
no reliable model explainer tool for the
multi-model design prediction model so
in this in this study we focus on the
best performance machine learning model
using only structured EHR data we apply
the model explainer tool shape on the
random first model to explore the
importance and impact of the features
shape value is against the radical
approach to explain the output of a
machine learning model the goal of shape
is to explain the prediction of any data
pointing X by Computing the contribution
of each feature to the prediction with
the shape value we can calculate the
marginal contribution of each features
and get its impact on the prediction
the basic idea comes from shapely value
it's a solution Concept in Cooperative
gen Theory which was introduced by the
old shapely in 1951.
here's a illustration example of shapely
value assume there are we have four
players they work together for a cargo
competition and they get a word and have
some payout so the question is how can
we fairly distribute this payout and the
strictly value was used to calculate the
marginal contribution for each player
and then we can barely
distribute this payout so this idea
applied to the machine learning so in
the trend model each feature will work
as a player and the Machine learning
model will be the game and
so and a prediction will be the payout
so by this way we can uh fairly
calculate the marginal contribution for
each feature for the prediction
here's the equation of the sharply value
Phi represents the Shipley value of a
feature I for the one data point and
small n is the total number of features
a big m without I content all the
possible feature except that not
containing the feature it and the big S
is the one feature subset from the
beginning the number of s is the size of
subset features and v x is the trim
model prediction function and small X is
the factor of feature value of a data
point
and the red red angle shows the marginal
contribution and the blue red angle is
the weight up for the combinations
so overall sharply value is used to
calculate the local feature contribution
for each data point and we can also get
a global interpretation like feature
importance uh based on the aggregation
of shape Leaf value
the figure shows the global feature
importance in our random forest model
since we want to know the global
importance we can average the absolute
shape values per feature across the data
and the feature with larger absolute
shape value are important and then will
sort the feature by decreasing the
importance so in in this plot the most
important factor is intraocular pressure
two to four weeks after the surgery
which is similar to previous findings on
study that showed the post-operative IOP
day 30 during that the period is the
most important predictor for the
long-term High IOP
and some other Factor like patience age
the medication use and the previous
surgery are also important in this
important feature importance plot
also the feature important plot is
useful but how can we tell the effect of
each feature for each class
so we can use the shape summary plot
here is the shape summary plot in our
study for the surgical value to do the
Phi IOP
so in the shape plot each point
um is a shape value of a feature for a
data point and the y-axis is determined
by the feature and uh the feature are
older according to their importance and
access shows the shape value and the
color represents the value of the
feature it's not for the shape values
for the feature value and the
overlapping Point are jetted in the
y-axis
so the feature summary plots shows the
basic relationship between the value of
feature and the impact on the prediction
for each class
it won't dig deeply for the independent
or a single feature and their
correlation to the prediction outcome
and uh has a more clear clearly
relationship plot we can use the shape
dependence plot
this figure shows the feature dependent
for the IOP value in two to four weeks
after surgery is the most important
feature in our study
so the shape feature depends on plot
shows a local feature importance over
all feature value of the data the y-axis
is the shape value it's in indicator
impact on prediction and the x-axis is
the value of the feature so um and each
point are the data point specific data
point we we use in the shape model that
can be the test data or training data up
here we use the test data to explain the
model
and in the dependent part the positive
shift value means increase the predict
risk of the output class and the
negative shape value means decrease the
predict risk of the output class
actually in the shape summary plot each
row was projecting from the point of the
shape dependence plot on the y-axis and
recoloring by the feature value
in the following slide we will show
several
um summary plot and dependent plot about
about our important feature finding in
the random Forex model here is again the
post-operative week two to four IOP
mixtures so we can see a clear linear
relationship between the feature value
and their prediction effect on the uh
surgical value due to high IOP and the
higher IOP increased the predict risk
and low IOP decrease the predicted risk
here is another example of important
feature as a binary inputs so the
product blending medication if patient
did not use this Inc so that will
increase the predicted risk of the
circle value to the high IOP and
decrease the risk if patient use the
protocol ending and the prior cataract
surgery feature shows the
country effect
um compared to the
post-glanding eye drops and here is a
another feature with less important
which is the post-operative IOP Day 2 to
14. so we can see there is no clear
relationship and uh with pretty uh the
range of the shape is pretty small
that's that's is is the same as clinical
findings since after the primary surgery
the IOP is always fluctuation during the
first two weeks and so that's the last
prediction Powers
um yeah
and here's the summary plot for the
surgical value to due to the low IOP
right now it's not for the high IOP so
we can see the
um post-operative week two to four IOP
is still the most important one and uh
shows a linear relationship but compared
to the high IOP case the linear
relationship is not as clear as the
higher op and in the lower IOP
prediction law IP surgical value
prediction the law
uh low IOP during that period increased
the predict risk
here is a product Landing eye drop for
the surgical value due to low IOP so
contrary to the um surgical value due to
high IOP proc Landing used before the
surgery will increase the predicted risk
of surgical value due to low IOP
and other than the surgical value plot
we can also explore the surgical success
plot so here is well again the close
operative week two to four IOP is still
the the most important one but in its
dependency plot we can see the
um there's no clear linear relationship
and we can found there's many points
that has the same feature value but
their effect can be positive or negative
so which indicates if you want to use a
single value even it's the most
important one in our model uh make a
prediction for the long-term outcome
will be pretty difficult
we also notice that age shows a linear
relationship for the surgical uh success
rate senior patient increased their
predict probability of surgical success
and younger patient should decrease the
predict probability of surgical success
so from the N3 we found the IOP mixture
in the two to four weeks after surgery
is the most important predictor of the
long-term surgical outcome for both
structure value so and which is similar
to the previous study finding and we saw
we also found some interesting features
like post Blending Eye drop used before
the surgery and prior cataract surgery
or the linear relationship of the age
and the surgical success rate this
feature is haven't been cleared the or
the result is controversial so it can be
a possible risk factor of the surgical
outcome for the future study
the key takeaway from its N3 is machine
learning model with a structured EHR
data has a predict power for surgical
outcome and the model explainer can
provide insight into the important
features associated with the multi-class
outcome and the identified factors can
be used to improve the clinical care or
help with the direction for a future
clinical study
however there are several limitations
need to be noticed also our data set was
one of the largest clinical observation
data set with detailed information about
galactomy outcomes the sample size is
still limited due to the nature of the
study in a single Institute since the
study was provided a single is to the
result might not be generalizable to
other Health Care system and we
currently don't have a reliable model
planner for the multi-model neural net
work model explanation
in the feature to improve the accuracy
and the generalizability of the model we
plan to combine image data such as OCD
Data before the surgery in our
multi-modal neural network and included
data from other Institute also because
of the novel Finding from the model
explainer we are planning to perform a
retrospective clinical study focus on
the preposectomy risk factor with
multi-class outcomes
so in summary my first study explored AI
application using EHR data for idcs
showing there were limited study focused
on glaucoma surgical outcome prediction
with several notable limitations
and I cling and validate the structure
here chart data with our fractured EHR
data improve the data quality and
develop a custom word embedding model
for the surgical node also I figured out
the accuracy issue of the medication
list for the glaucoma patients and
develop a medication reconciliation tool
using the natural language algorithm and
the usability of medication list for the
prediction model was also explored
overall this work has the implication in
improving the data quality and the
usefulness for the medication data in
both research and clinical care
in the end one uh sorry in the end too I
developed several machine learning and
deep learning model with structure and
unstructured EHR data to predict the
multi-classical outcomes
um this study is one of the first and
largest clinical opacity of observation
data set with detailed information about
the tropical ectomy outcomes uh combine
both structure and unstructured EHR data
also the usefulness of surgical nodes as
a predictor in the multi-class outcome
production model was presented it has a
potential to apply this concept to the
other clinical specialty and the multi
multi-model prediction neural network
could could correctly identify 50
percent or more surgical value cases so
it can be an assistant tool for the
clinical decision making
and lastly in our specific entry we
developed a model X planner for our
random forest model to identify risk
factor associated with the high IOP or
low IOP surgical value and explore their
importance and their effect on the
surgical outcomes
so I would like to thank you my mentor
Dr Mitchell quiver and Dr Michael Chan
and all my communities thank you for
your time your support and your guide
and really appreciate it also I would
like to thank you all my research group
member Jimmy Adam Aaron Isaac and Ernest
I got a lot of help in many Pleasant
hour work with you guys
and thank you for the wonderful staff
and faculty in oshu at D mice and KCI
institutes basically I want to thank you
Diane Andrea Virginia and Abby I got a
lot of Health uh along the way besides I
want to thank you my fellow students and
qualified exam coher Rose lady Mina da
and Chris and all demise fellows and I
want to thank again for my mentor Dr
Mitchell quiver for all your support and
your insightful suggestion for my
projects also I would like to thank you
again for the Michael Chan Dr Michael
Chan and Dr Karen Eden for advising me
to start my PhD journey and support
supporting me along the way and finally
I'd like to send you my family
especially for my wife my parents and my
sister and the founding from the uh and
I uh National Library of Medicine yeah
so so that's my work thank you for
listening
stop sharing your screen so we save
those questions and the next I have a
question uh let me start sharing yeah
that way just so we could save them
oops
is here yeah
are people still there
this is good
foreign
slides are
yeah
that's without the slides but the WebEx
just uh
um
yeah uh the WebEx is in my Monitor but
like oh okay yeah
okay so then I'm gonna quit at it
some connection issues
okay you can let me just take a look at
that
um
so my my screen is still the web access
oh okay interesting the the screen here
in section well let me um let me uh and
and are there um
so people can either type questions in
the chat or can unmute
um but I'm gonna take the prerogative
and ask the first question
um the the medication reconciliation so
you said there was a 36
error rate uh discrepancy discrepancy
for our manual review 150 progress note
and um so between what was in the
progress note and like the medication
list or yeah because we include some um
counterpart I mean not the uh it's some
like artificial fluid or some nuts yeah
like Hospital prescription medication as
our list and what was the direction of
the errors was it like
um some Arrow come from like duplicate
prescription and prescription actually
stopped but not showing in the
medication list and some other is like
patient take medication from the other
pharmacology of Pharmacy but they're not
taking medication from the OSU so the
medication doesn't list this okay and so
the so your gold standard then was what
was in the note yeah yeah would you
assume um it's not can be like purely
goes down there but we believe
individually we try to uh extract active
medication so that means like Physicians
will record some like drug use uh
patients like taking or starts so we try
to focus on the active medication we
assume that's more reliable yeah okay
and and so and then you kind of um
um you sort of
narrowed it down into categories which
actually makes a lot of sense you know
um you know so I mean I I guess um
um well that kind of clarifies things
and I I mean I I guess maybe the
question is
um
um
you know is there concern about the
um well you I I guess your assumption is
that you're mapping the different drugs
into the specific categories and so that
that is what goes into your model
preserve some information well actually
in the beginning we try to treat each
medication unique medication is some
embedding method similar to the wedding
batting so we tried to the work to
factor treat each medication as a word
and each physi as a sentence or
recommendation system to get a
medication embedding but probably due to
the sample size and then there are too
many unique medication we input this
medication embedding in our production
model but they cannot converge and make
things Mass okay so we figure out that's
probably like issue of medication list
itself or the the noise generated during
retrained meditation embedding but it's
interesting try yeah yeah okay yeah I
mean it just goes to show the the
challenges of working with EHR data this
is just another example of it are there
other questions see I wanted to go ahead
and um I don't know if there's any
further up and there's a few
congratulations and so forth
um but there's a a question from Nate
there yeah for our transfer Inc uh not
ask uh oh I don't need to read again
yeah so we we don't use the pre-trim
model we just used the um Transformer
encoder block that that architecture and
with our pre-trend 50 Dimension what
embedding to extract this information to
come concatenate with our structure here
child data in our prediction model so we
did not use the pre-trim pre-trim bird
if anyone has any questions they can
also unmute
maybe I'll I'll ask one more question
um your your
um
recall Precision f-score were were good
but not perfect so
um
what are the
um ramifications of that if people are
going to use this tool clinically
currently I think
um it can it can be just if that apply
into the clinical setting it can just be
a system tool to so probably provide
some probability of the patient has a
higher risk of high op or low iot for
the long term so still need to position
and human expert to make the judgment to
did I agree this
probability or not yeah
okay
and then seems to like limited symbol
size well thinking there's a possible
include like OCT Data before surgery or
something collaborate with other
Institute in in enlarged sample size
right
any other questions out there
okay well if not we can uh we can leave
wei-chan to his committee they may have
some additional questions
um uh this is really great work and it's
really interesting uh to see you know
kind of a real world clinical
application of
um machine learning like this so
um I'll look forward to Future uh
Endeavors so we we can excuse including
myself the non-members of the committee
and then um you guys can take it from
there